how's it going everybody today we got
some interesting news we have new
information in regards to the Snyder cut
of Justice League a lot of people have
been talking about the Snyder cut for a
really long time now and a lot of people
are even starting to wonder if it even
exists well have no fear because yes it
does exist his cut may not be complete
but there are actually rumors that he
has started working on it on his own
outside of a studio so it does in fact
exist don't worry about that the
question is will we ever see it and if
we do will it be good well luckily at
San Diego comic-con Jason Momoa answered
this question for us but first and
foremost for those of you who aren't
familiar with what the Justice League
Snyder cut is let me explain director
Zack Snyder who has directed many things
in the past such as Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice was hired to direct
Justice League but was unfortunately
fired before all of the editing took
place after he was fired he was replaced
by Joss Whedon who directed the Avengers
Whedon oversaw post-production and did
some very extensive reshoots and the
result was the Justice League that we
got which many fans were disappointed
about as well as the general audience
due to that disappointment many fans
petitioned that we should be able to see
the version that Zachary Snyder directed
when Snyder directed Batman for Superman
dawn of Justice the studio ended up
releasing a director's cut of the movie
and the director's cut was quite a bit
better and a lot of fans were hoping
that Justice League would get the same
treatment as Batman vs Superman
releasing the Snyder cut but the studio
has shut this down time and time again
so it doesn't seem like we're going to
get it at least not anytime soon however
there is good news about it at Comic Con
Jason Momoa told an audience Justice
League was good but Snyder's cut is
better so
double boom it's better than what we saw
and although it looks like we may not
receive it anytime soon this statement
kind of does imply that we actually
might see it soon when he talks about
Justice League he says it was good and
when he talks about the Snyder cut he
says Snyder's cut is better not was
better is better implying that it's
finished so maybe we are about to get
something and if we do I sure hope it's
better there was a video rail released
of Snyder's own edit of the Justice
League just a small clip maybe a minute
and a half long but it was released not
too long ago and I liked it more than
anything I saw in the movie so hopefully
it does get released at some point or
another whether it's better or not
doesn't really matter to me I would just
be excited to see it what do you all
think about Jason Momoa comment at Comic
Con and what do you all think about the
possible release of Zack Snyder's cut of
Justice League let me know in the
comments below and be sure to like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on Justice League
Snyder cut Marvel DC and everything
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you